the future at our thule springs regional  park is bright now we've got about a  40-acre park coming to us here in the  next two years that's just going to be a  great asset for everyone in that  neighborhood it's sort of up by um the  aliante casino in 215 in that area  but we're going to have three multi-use  fields aka soccer fields  we'll have four baseball  softball fields we'll have a lot of  basketball uh we'll have a playground  it's flashpad for all the kids to come  out and enjoy the  water  plus vault sand volleyball and a lot of  green space and walking  paths now for everybody to come out and  enjoy  we'll obviously have shade structures  out there and restrooms and good parking  to support all the sports that's going  to be happening at that park